[Music]
[Applause]
all right let me bring in mike florio
pro football talk live
co-host you can see his show on peacock
every morning monday through friday
let me start there mike out of those
quarterbacks which team should be moving
on
well i think without question it's the
49ers from jimmy garoppolo he's missed
23 games over the past three seasons
he's got a 25 million dollar
compensation package this year
and i think back to the playoff run in
2019 he freaked out kyle shanahan in the
game against the vikings
throwing three balls that could have
been intercepted by eric kendricks one
of them was
that's when they shifted to bob greasy
mode for the rest of the post season
at least until the super bowl and had
him just hand the ball off to that
that great stable of running backs they
have and also receivers who can run the
football
but i think they'd be far better off if
they upgraded at the quarterback
position and would be
a super bowl contender if not a super
bowl favorite with a better quarterback
do they have plans on doing that well
they're keeping their cards close to the
vest right now because of the cap
consequences of trading or cutting jimmy
garoppolo it would not be
a significant blow to their overall
structure for
other contracts and other players i
think they just need to find
a better quarterback before they make a
move on jimmy g i don't think they trade
him
because i don't think anybody wants to
pay him 25 million dollars for next year
i think they
will look for somebody better and if
they find somebody better they'll go get
that person
maybe try to trade him ultimately
potentially just cut him
when you can't find someone else to take
on that commitment all because of the
inability to stay healthy dan
does it make sense for the steelers to
bring ben back
because it's money-based that hey we'll
have you come back but
only if you you know you you're going to
play at a reasonable salary here
or does it make more sense to be moving
on to start with whatever
you know the new era next generation is
with this team
dan my understanding that is that this
is not about
trying to pay ben roethlisberger less
than what he's due to make this year now
that they're at the point where they've
decided
they want to continue this relationship
you have to take his contract one year
left
41.25 million dollar cap charge for this
year
22.25 million is counting against the
cap no matter what they do if he retires
if he's cut
if he restructures his contract that
22.25 is going nowhere
the question is with the 19 he's due to
make this year what do you do
to shrink the cap charge this year push
some of those dollars into future years
it's very easy to do
it should only take an hour that part of
it is easy and now that they're at the
point
where that's the next step assuming the
steelers are willing to pay him 19
million for this
year it's something that literally could
be done in an hour
i don't know why it's taken so long to
get to this point i think some of it was
the steelers asking themselves
are we going to be good enough this year
to justify one more year with big ben
and i think from his perspective he has
to look at it and say
is the team going to be good enough for
me to give it one more run
i don't think this is quite 2005 jerome
bettis
we're just that close away from the
super bowl let's try to do it one last
time and walk off into the sunset with a
trophy
i really do believe and i know i may i
may eat these words
later in the year i think come november
and december
both sides are going to regret this one
more year this feels like brett favre in
2010
i think both sides would be better off
moving on has anybody
seen desean watson i don't
i i think there was a photo of him like
in miami or something he's
really handling this in a in a a quiet
private discreet way the texans know
where he's coming from
he's yet to go public i suggested last
week that at some point he may have to
go public to put pressure on the texans
to do something he's making it too easy
for them to just hang up the phone
whenever anyone calls with an offer and
just
take the position that they believe at
some point he's going to
change his mind about not wanting to be
there and there was a great item in the
athletic last week about
this situation how it got to this point
and one of the comments about
his nature he's very stoic by design he
was inspired by his mother's cancer
fight that she handled everything very
very even keeled and i think that that's
that's who he is he doesn't
want to have to go public he doesn't
want to have to throw grenades
at the texans in an interview or
somewhere else he wants them to figure
out on their own what their best move is
and we'll see if they do
yeah you start to wonder if you're
desean watson and you go okay i'm going
to go to a team that
i might deplete their roster or their
future roster
do i want to go to carolina and all of a
sudden i'm
going to you know it's a lateral move
now i get out from underneath whatever
he's bothered by with the texans but
it's not like he's going to go to a
place
where they're gonna go hey add water and
stir
we're ready to challenge for a
championship here yeah that's the
problem i mean the herschel walker type
trade
you end up being the guy who gets traded
to the team that doesn't have any first
round draft picks for the next three
years or second or third or give up this
guy and that guy
the greater the package to get to sean
watson the harder it is for that team
where he lands
to compete and and that's part of the
challenge in finding the right team here
the texans
if they're going to trade him they're
going to want maximum compensation
before desean watson waves his no trade
clause he's going to want to feel like
he's not jumping from one bad situation
into another
if you were going to handicap this give
me the teams
in order well i i
i really think what's going to happen is
the texans aren't going
to entertain offers and the teams that
that would be there right now
are going to begin to scatter as they
make other plans see that's the problem
with not realizing your best move
is to get all interested teams to the
table now
and play them against each other like
detroit did with stafford
exactly now here's the time let's go
let's do this now
because if they don't and you decide to
do it
in august when he doesn't show up and
then you realize oh he was serious about
that
yeah he was well how many teams are
going to have in august
september october trade deadline that's
what dwayne brown did
four years ago he held out he wanted to
be traded they said no no no no no
he finally shows up and then they trade
him to the seahawks and they don't get
nearly as much as they would have gotten
if they just would have done it back in
march or april
dan look i i the only way i can make
sense of this because look at all the
changes that texans are making
new culture firing this person this
person doesn't fit the culture doesn't
fit the culture you got a franchise
quarterback who says i don't want to be
part of the culture
well then why don't you trade him i keep
going back to the catch phrase that the
late bob mcnair gave the nfl during the
anthem controversy the founder of the
texans
we can't have the inmates running the
prison i feel like that's the attitude
that's being sent and directed it to
sean watson as a message to him and all
the rest of the players you guys just
work here
we can't have the inmates running to
prison we decide who stays
we decide who gets traded we decide who
gets what they want
you don't make that decision that's the
only way any of this makes sense to me
yeah i thought lynch would be traded but
i didn't think desean watson would be
traded
but if they're not i don't know who's
making it public that they're not
taking offers it feels like the texans
might be
telling the media hey we're not taking
offers so it gets out
that you know teams can still hey we
haven't
heard the coming we haven't heard the
offer that we want yet
i mean your best leverage think about it
somebody shows up at your door and wants
to buy your house your best leverage is
i ain't selling well then the offer goes
up i really want this house well i'm not
selling offer goes up i really want this
house i'm not selling if you can if you
can sell that
you get more the eagles weren't in a
position to sell that
because it was obvious the eagles were
going to move on from carson wentz
with the texans yeah even though it
seems
dumb that they wouldn't do this thing
and get the best offer they can now if
they can make people think they
really are committed to holding on to
deshaun watson
maybe what happens is somebody gets a
little desperate and when they're at
that pivot point where they either have
to
go get deshaun watson or move on to plan
b instead of moving on to plan b
they they throw something else onto the
pile and the texans come out of it even
better
when nick casario addressed the issue
during the press conference
that introduced their new coach david
cully i didn't read
casario as being lying in the sand
no way in hell i interpreted some things
he said
as meaning that that they were going to
realize that it's in their best interest
to take the best package now that
assumes he's he's got the authority
to convince anyone there to do it you
never know what cal mcnair as
as influenced by jack easterby is going
to do talking to mike florio pro
football talk
you can see the show every morning
monday through friday along with
chris sims i also wondered about this
with dak prescott
that jerry jones could have stumbled
into a situation that might benefit him
and that is
hey i tag him one more time at what 36
37 million dollars and he's coming back
from an injury
if it doesn't go well i get out from
underneath this now if it does go well
then we sign him to a long-term deal
because i don't think you want to
do a tag him at 50 million or 52 million
dollars
so it could either be really really good
for dallas or it could be
really really bad give me give me jerry
jones
strategy through all of this well the
strategy has been
wait for dak prescott to finally realize
that he should do a team-friendly deal
that strategy has not been effective and
the more they wait
the more the price goes up because think
about this scenario dan
one more year 37.68 million first of all
the caps going
down this year this is not the year to
have 37.68 million
in cap dollars tied to one player but
let's say that works and he's healthy
and you want to keep him
the problem is when you go to sign him
to a long-term deal next year
he's got all the leverage because the
only way to keep him from the open
market
is to use the franchise tag again at a
44
raise 54.25 million he's getting to the
open market next year
if you don't sign him to a long term
contract this year you know there's been
this lingering question what is dak
prescott really worth we don't know what
he's really worth yeah because the
cowboys won't let him go to the open
market
the entire franchise tag you know
they've tried to spin it as it's some
sort of an honor that's bs
this is a device that the teams have to
keep
players from getting fair market value
because they don't get to find out
what other teams will pay next year if
they don't do a long-term deal now
dak prescott gets to find out what other
teams would pay but why don't they just
let him go to market if somebody wants
to sign him you get two first-round
picks
i mean well they crossed this bridge
last year dan all they had to do
was use the non-exclusive franchise tag
it would have been 27 million 26 million
something like that
instead of 31.4 it was 31.4 because they
used the exclusive tag
it's a higher price for most positions
especially it is for quarterback the way
the formula
is different and it seals off the
opportunity for someone
to sign him and give two first-round
picks as compensation they
and and because someone said to me last
year oh look next year they won't use
the franchise tag my reaction was and
this was before the broken ankle
why wouldn't they they've already used
the highest possible level of the tag
to keep them around they they they are
committed to this guy
the problem is they've always believed
that there's going to be this lightning
bolt
where dak prescott says you know what
i've i've built
leverage and i've built leverage and
i've built leverage
i'm just going to go ahead and give it
up and do you guys a favor
and sign a contract that doesn't reflect
the leverage that i've accumulated
when do we find out about the 17th
regular season game
i think it's tied to the tv contracts
there was a fact that maybe the tv
contracts were
being finalized so they could move some
money around and bump up the salary cap
my understanding is
they're trying to get the tv contracts
done before they make it official with
17 games
and i saw a report from the washington
post 17 and
three preseason games which makes sense
you want to hold that third preseason
game
so the next move is 18-2 they've had 20
games forever
back when but in the 70s i remember six
preseason games in 14 regular season
games it was ridiculous but i think
eighteen and two
at some point down the road is where
we're headed they won't go 17 and two
they'll go 17 and three and then 18 and
two oh boy
yeah i was told this morning it's all
tied to tv dollars you know got to get
the contracts done
and then everybody knows what they're
going to make and uh then we're going to
have that 17th game
more inventory more stuff to bet on i
think they need to have more windows
don't be surprised if there's some sort
of a double header package in the next
monday night football deal
more standalone games where people can
bet on those games especially as the
technology improves
to the point where what you see at home
on your tv is happening
at the exact same moment so you can pick
up the cell phone device
and make a bet on whatever the next play
is going to be uh when's j.j watt make
his decision
well i think i think that that teams
won't know what they can offer him
until they know what the salary caps
going to be and i think we're probably
a week week and a half away from
figuring out what the cap's going to be
first the teams have to figure out what
they want it to be
some want it to be lower some want it to
be higher and then they have to work out
the agreement with the union as to what
it's going to be but
you know when he got his freedom two
weeks ago
the the first thing i thought of hey it
gets a 33 day head start to the open
market and i thought about it's like
nobody knows what the cap's going to be
you don't know what you can pay them
and the other side of it too is if you
give that
five six seven million whatever it is to
jj watt you may find out
later that another team unexpectedly cut
a guy
to get under the cap and you look at him
and say man i could have
spent that money on this guy instead
because even though watt
you know great player hall of famer
three-time defensive player of the year
he's 32 and he's had an injury history
there may be other guys out there when
you take the name off the back of the
jersey the teams will look at and say
i'd kind of rather have him
oh we played the j.j watt game yesterday
a quick recap there paulie
uh i went with the he would play in los
angeles for the chargers of the rams
uh fritzy went with the cowboys mclovin
went with
packers seton steelers i went with
buffalo
i like buffalo i'm with you on buffalo
buffalo all right
every tweet from jjwat2 gets paper
analyzed to see where the
it's like it's like you know we used to
spin the record backwards i buried paul
like where's the clue where's the clue
on on the
jj twitter page as to where he's gonna
go thank you mike as always we
appreciate your time
all right see you dan mike floria pro
football talk a website
profootballtalk.com pro football talk
live